In general, people find they're most similar to their
immediate family because they're most related to them. More distant
family members still show similarities, but fewer similarities than
the closely related family. For example, you might compare yourself
to one of your parents, say your mother, and
you might be looking at traits that you share in
common. And then we can look at your mother's parents,
one her parents. Let's say her father, your grand daddy,
and we could essentially compare the same traits among
all of us. And we could keep going back in
time looking at the parents of the grandparents and the
parents of the great grandparents, and the parents of the
great-great grandparents. And we could just keep gong back in
this very linear fashion. In general, you're probably going to find
that you're most similar to your parent and then your
grandparent, and then your great grandparent as a general rule.
But looking at families in this very linear
fashion isn't really all that accurate, and it's really
difficult to make comparisons to all the other family
members that you're related to. Your family actually resembles
much more of a shrub-like structure, with branches
coming off to the sides, up and to the
right, all around, going back in time in many
different directions. We can represent half siblings, aunts, uncles,
granddads, uncles, cousins and so on. Let's actually
try to look at this starting with your
most immediate biological family members. Your parents, father
and mother, and your siblings, sister or brother.
Now you share 100% similarity with yourself. Congratulations,
you are you. And with all of these
other immediate family members: father, mother, sister, brother,
your sharing about 50% similarity. This tier of relatedness
is the closest tier of relatedness to you
with regards to your family members, those people
with whom you're genetically related. Now let's add
the first tier of complexity here. Your mother and
father may have siblings, these would be considered
your aunts and uncles. Your aunts and uncles, and
your parents all share parents themselves, your grandparents.
This tier of relatedness is roughly 25% to you,
this tier also includes relatives like half siblings.
A half sibling is someone who shares one biological
parent with you. Now you notice that when
we added one tier of complexity, we got a
lot bigger pretty fast. Right. We added a
bunch of levels both in the same generation as
you. The generation above you and another generation beyond
that. Now we can add another tier. And keep
building your family tree or your family shrub in
this case. We've added many more great grandparents. Some
grand aunts and grand uncles, some first cousins here.
And we can keep building, and keep building this tree
or shrub, or as I like to think of it a family rainbow. And we can start at the
center here with perfect genetic relatedness and keep moving
out to the next rung, to the next part of
the rainbow, and we get less and less related. And as we build, we just
get bigger and bigger. Our family stretches
on and on in many directions. We're including
great great grandparents, second cousins, first cousins
once removed. This visual really brings to light
the shrubbiness of our families, and our
family trees. Now, with a visual like this,
which of the following inferences is the
least well described? Would it be family relatedness,
genetic relatedness, or trait relatedness? Go ahead
and pick the answer you think best applies.